je refuse de compter les points en fait
j'ai l'impression justement il y a tout
un discours qui est fait pour entretenir
une guerre des sexes
je trouve stupide notant d'ailleurs
qu'en plus ils devaient vraiment y avoir
gardé c'est que je ne suis même pas
certain que les femmes puissent la
gagner donc je pense pas que ce sont
leurs intérêts je crois qu'il faut au
contraire chercher plutôt la
complémentarité tout le reste et vous
voyez quand je pense à l'histoire je
vais utiliser un argument personnel je
sais que c'est là pour le coup c'est
facile dans un débat je le sais mais je
vais quand même le faire mon à montner
grand-mère était mariée à un homme qui
travaillaient dans les mines de charbon
à alès il est mort à verdun
il travaillait il a travaillé toute sa
vie il est mort jeune donc il a pour
donner de la nourriture à la famille il
est mort à la guerre pour protéger son
foyer mon arrière grand mère
eh bien elle traîne ne travaillait pas
elle s'occupait des foyers et des
différentes familles elle s'est remariée
par la suite avec des enfants elle a eu
une longue vie est ce que vraiment j'ai
envie d'aller me demander qui était des
deux le plus opprimé qui a le plus
souffert et tout ça j'ai pas envie de
rentrer dans cette considération stupide
de du comptage de points qui tous soumis
qu'il est qu ils étaient les témoins
encore une fois je trouve que ce
discours est absolument réducteur
stupide et nous entraîne vers vers je
crois année l'isthme absolue puisque là
où nous devons travailler en fait c'est
plutôt d'essayer de trouver un féminisme
qui s'occupe davantage du bonheur des
femmes plutôt que de la haine des hommes
parce qu'en fait ce discours là j'ai
l'impression que ce disque au post
féministe et des hommes qui cherchent à
leur plaire j'ai l'impression ces
édifices vous et qu'ils aiment les
femmes qu'elle aime les femmes qu'on ait
bolchévique et mais les ouvriers voyez
je s'intéressent pas en réalité alors
alors leur sort et améliorer les choses
et donc la vie entre les deux sexes et
quant aux hommes parce que peut-être il
serait bien de passer aux hommes et
puisque c'est quand même l'objet du
débat on en parle et bien eu à travers
justement ces évolutions naturelles
il faut et moi je suis fais partie des
gens qui pensent qu'il faut remettre à
jour la virilité la mettre à jour au
sens de l'amendé y réfléchir mais la
chose c'est que là pourquoi yat-il cette
remise en question de la viabilité
actuelle parce que nous vivons en europe
occidentale et en europe occidentale
seulement parce qu aux etats unis ce
n'est pas le cas ou si ce n'est pas le
cas en afrique n'est pas le cas dans le
monde arabe ce n'est pas le cas en asie
c'est pas le cas partout mais on a
beaucoup de pays en asie ce n'est pas le
cas nous sommes dans un état des choses
et de pensée qui nous fait croire que
nous sommes sortis de l'histoire que
nous sommes sortis du tragique et qui
est donc
sommes sortis en fait de la sélection
naturelle et lab et de la compétition
sexuelle aussi
or nous y sommes et la virilité à quoi
sert-elle précisément à faire bella
figura dans la sélection naturelle
c'est-à-dire à survivre et à trouver
partenaires dans la compétition sexuelle
or dans cette post modernité j'insiste
sur ce mot les états d'y aller les
individus d'aujourd'hui en tout cas ce
qui tient lieu de pensée
on se croit des individus coupé de tout
couper du naturel coupé de la nature ce
qui est d'ailleurs assez drôle à une
époque qui se veut écologique puisque en
fait elle dénie la nature en elle et
autour de nous eh bien elle se prend
coupé de tout nous n'avons plus
nationaux n'avons pu de biologie nous
n'avons absolument aucune différence
entre les hommes et les femmes
la sélection naturelle n'opère plus donc
il n'y a plus besoin d'être viré le sens
n'est plus besoin de se tenir droit face
à l'existence et à ces drames
alors que les drames sont précisément en
train de revenir
[Musique]